hey what's up guys Marcus Varela here
from mkbhd and I have another hardware
unboxing video for you guys now you
might have thought the LG Voyager
Hardware case reviews or unboxings were
over and I in fact so did I but this one
has comes to us here from Santa cases it
did take a little while to ship because
UPS was unable to deliver to a home
address so they had to switch over give
it back and USPS was able to ship this
so this is the same at cases unboxing
video for the LG VX 10000 and I'll post
this as a video response to the harder
overview just in case you don't know
what it looks like so let's just go
ahead and get into the box here I'll see
you at the end here we go there we go so
as we open right up here we see a box
that says st. out on the front or Cena I
might be pronouncing that wrong and a
little bit of shipping information from
Santa cases so um that's all they came
in the box so basically looks like a
nice box actually here I'm not going to
need this nice anymore
and looks like a nice box we'll go ahead
and see what's inside and here is the
case it's actually surprisingly inside
of a pouch which is actually a nice
touch and it comes with a little little
piece of paper here that says Santa on
it it says how to remove your device
from the ultra slim pouch so this is in
fact the ultra slim pouch just go ahead
and open this up and here is the leather
ultra slim pouch for the LG Voyager says
Santa on this side and it's blank on the
other side
smells actually definitely that is
definitely leather and you can obviously
slide your device into here and I guess
you can you can put it in the pouch if
you like but I'm probably going to have
it in my pocket inside the pouch now I
do have the phone here and it'll
probably work for a little more than
just the LG Voyager but that does fit
just fine now I don't want to get too
far into a review or impressions right
and here in the unboxing video because I
save that for the full 100% review video
but looking so far so good guys so
thanks to the folks at Santa cases for
sending this out to me looks very nice
so far I hope to get you guys with the
review video of this product in one to
two weeks for me using this and it's
nice that they came with a case with a
pouch that's very nice that Santa does
that anyway thanks for subscribing
thanks for watching my videos please
comment below what do you think of this
this package that fanny gives you is
that good is that if that normal what do
you think thanks for subscribing thanks
for watching my videos and that's
basically it guys have a nice day
peace